good morning my name is Michaela garden
and I am the Associate Director at the
center for molecular on carotid
pathology which needs desires within and
dana farber and so SEMA is a hunter
which supports collaborative quality
based research projects that have
potential results and applications for
targeted cancer therapy with the
particular focus on prostate cancer and
so today I'm going to talk about
automated or NAC sample preparation for
archival ffpe tissue specimens and we're
going to talk about prostate cancer
tissue specimens so I'm prostate cancer
is if one of the most widely prevalence
and cancer diseases and there are
currently about two important as in the
cases of prostate cancer and that will
be diagnosed a year 2013 and of which
it's projected that approximately 30,000
people will die so it's the second
leading cause of death in men and
there's a higher rate of incidence in
and unmoor tality and african-americans
and some information is known about is
it's not fully understood why that
indicates the only established risk
factor that and most people have are
able to look at if age where sixty
percent of diagnosis if diamond men over
65 middle-aged and so currently right
now the standard practice is routine if
they testing for early detection but
obviously the idea would be to find more
valuable biomarkers and uppercuts and so
the major challenge we face in prostate
cancer is distinguishing between in
Burlington aggressive types with the
tendency to reoccur and two most
research activities that were involved
in a focused on is better understanding
this distinction
okay so what I'm talking to talk about
today is a collaboration that we had
with a beckman filter and we had a goal
to optimize this great seat life in
preparation method for ethically samples
of varying degradation and we wanted to
develop an automated method or this
library on the biomat biomagnetic speed
platform and then we wanted to give
utilize the platform to prepare library
for a particular person tents or cohorts
that we have enhanced so the big inning
of that and parking but its tissues is
that this is the routine preservation
methods that is used to our hospitals
for research our kind collections are
stored for decades and they're an
invaluable tool for biomedical research
and large cohorts of samples are
required for any sort of meaningful
clinical discovery and put extensive RNA
and fragmentation and cross-linking have
been a limiting factor for clinical
translation applications which would
lead to biomarker discovery and so
apartment vetted tissues and impulsive
cancer you know typically there are two
specimen collection sites is a fine
needle aspirate and the core biopsies
and prostate cancer cannot be diagnosed
from frozen sections choose the
difficulty of the morphology so
predominantly the archival collection
that we have our and our formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue and so globally
we have these large-scale cohorts where
the fancy cancer and patient attended
President cabin archive and enhance we
have access to all of these samples and
the clinical annotation including
diagnosis prognosis etc to help us to
you retrospective studies
ok so the to the to the cohort has so
the FD a-- can PE specimens that we used
here we had 16 and cases where we had
matched ffpe specimens and fresh frozen
specimens until it's talk about a temper
the equity investment and from these e
were able to and I tomates tumor and
normal cells from the same case so these
tissue sections were prepared for hey
Keaney and they're reviewed by a
pathologist to classify first of all
identify and annotate where the tumor
glands and the normal that have done
where and then to classify the disease
state and with the Gleason score and and
so from these once this is done we had
tissue blocks or cord so we use corn
point years of 1.2 millimeter diameter
three core punches from each of the
regions of interest and then from those
we've prepared we automated the
extraction of the RNA using a form of
your kid and gives that quantified and
concedes yaar na for yield and quality
respectively and use 100 milligrams of
total RNA as the input for our NHD like
recovery
ok so the squirt see quartz them so and
the kippah used is called a scripting
complete the protocol its version 2 of
there are native library preparation and
it states that there are any input
levels in between 100 and 500 nanograms
with empathy tissues is an ounce be a
challenge because depending on the
degradation level of the sample and you
may find that if not always feasible to
get very high yields of quality RNA and
the descriptive workflow is as follows
there's three basic steps there's a
ribosomal RNA depletion three step and
purification of the sample which is
followed by a cdna synthesis and the
round purification and then thirdly we
have a library application of
purification and as you can see
relatively straightforward workflow and
can typically be handled in a single day
and this is a big advantage of this
method relative to quite a number of
other methods that exist and that it can
be done in one day there's basically
three steps and in order to ascertain
how the Wikipedia early unclean example
because the level of fragmentation is
quite high so we wanted to assess
purification strategies and so we looked
at what recommended with the protocol is
minimum time we also wanted to look at
magnetic games looking at the am pure
beef versus the spice and I need to see
if you think you better in terms of
cleanup so initially before automating
this method he wants to test on the
bench where we wear with a
representative sample and from our
cohort just to establish some of the key
parameters and so open the top left-hand
corner
so local news corner we have the
original RNA so this is bioanalyzer
trace and as you can see from this trade
so typically what you would see with a
bioanalyzer traits it's that when the
quality of your name is good you have to
think peeps representing a Venus and
permeate s these are usually in a ratio
of two to one if you're putting hye-rin
number in our case most of our samples
look like that so most of our examples
are five to ten years of age and so all
the RNA has completely degraded and you
get it's much smaller fragmentation p
for the RNA that remains and then from
this sometimes it's challenging to
generated written umber but the real
numbers range about 2.4 up to 44 the
best-case scenario for some of these
samples and so from previous experience
we have tested library prep methods and
left the ribosomal RNA component there
it's a very high percentage of our
sequencing data was around forever total
RNA so within next methods that we test
it we wanted to incorporate a ribosome
of the patient set so what represented
here is if the if the RNA that got
through ribosomal depletion and then
what we did on the back end is do a
purified cleanup and you can see a very
pretty stinky representing our ribosome
amoeba feeding RNA and so we took this
through the whole workflow and stuck to
the protocol parameters so we gave pcr
12 ER and pgr and on the back end we
compared a free cleanup methods so what
you can see here is on the left and
right side or the molecular markers and
the most and then here is the cDNA
library definitely prepared the big
thing here to point out if is large
anomalous peak its people's presence
when we use the mineral in columns and
it was reduced but it was reduced
dramatically when he gives the bead so
the blue represents the mineral
cleanup which actually looks like it
actually above examples of yourself up
and then if you look at the turquoise
and green pleats this is using the dbase
not only to get a higher yield of your
library we also have none of these
contaminating please Curtis and so just
to zoom in on that under am pure beads
you can see here that contaminated and
we have a nice vibe really generated
okay so um once we were confident with
what we were seeing on the bench scale
manual crap we translated this across to
the automated system and so in our first
run we ran in parallel eight samples on
a single lane of biomech system and this
is the same sample representative case
that i pulled up here and what you can
see here is that this is the same RNA
beginning to if I think rate when the
right azam of the patient is done on the
robot you can see what the library looks
like this is the cdna synthesis project
after cleanup and then you can see the
library doesn't generate it and I think
the big thing to point out here is done
it might be clearly going to 10 so if
the far superior means that we're
getting in the library when we run it on
the automated system so once we saw this
and we went ahead with our cohort which
is our 14 hour 14 pairs and run all of
these in parallel on the bio map ok so
just to give you a little idea of what
what I'm talking about when I talk about
the degradation of the leads i have ee
months as I said previously he took
recourse or punched on all the blocks
and they're from the annotated regions
of interest and within the tumor benign
areas and they were instructed by
automation Baptist and what part of here
is just right the big yield and yield
range if anything from 400 milligrams
from three quarters up to 66 microgram
so it's a huge range for talking about
in terms of the same
amount of tissue going into the
instruction method and what are to come
again on the backgrounds and some of
this is due to institution morphology
changes as if core punch into a block
but a lot of it is due to that these
blocks are not all centrally stored we
can be stored in various different
places so they've undergone degradation
due to humidity heat and just general
slow degradation autoclave as its over
time and so what you're seeing here is a
good representative type examples we're
trying to establish methods for and then
if you pull out a number of these
samples so we have tumor normal hair so
pair 12 / 24 / 11 and this is just to
give you an idea what is previous slides
this is what the RNA concentration of
like what this translates you in terms
of RNA degradation and on the bottom you
can see that in the case of couple 11 in
the tumor gets from here and the way
this trace looks is that there's
actually larger fragments of RNA still
present in this sample but then as you
look towards 24 and they go towards 12
the amount of actual degradation
increases substantially as you go up to
these samples summer 12 is the work
sample and in terms of degradation that
we actually ran and sample 11 was kind
of representative of maybe twenty
percent samples so we had more looking
like this but we had a couple that were
really low so we really wanted to a big
part of what we're going to do going
forward is let me get from generating
these sequencing data we want to
correlate some of the chromosomal
regions and some of the genes that are
being expressed to degradation level and
see if we can come up with a model for
determining which samples are feasible
for sequencing going forward and based
off each types of traces
okay so all of the samples were brought
through the library preparation method
and purified to the back ends using and
a beat based method and so these are the
this is the quantification data from the
cDNA libraries generated and again you
can see due to extensive degradation and
a high level of fragmentation you can
see that the yields from our libraries
also vary greatly from and even from 50
up to 1,800 milligrams so again you're
saying the same spread across across the
cohort and so getting into some of the
some of the basic you see metrics from
these life leads that were generated so
we looked at fragment size across the
cohort and this is actually relatively
uniform considering considering how the
yields range dramatically so we have a
fragment average size range of between
210 and for 20 in this one particular
sample on the content here which didn't
perform particularly well but overall
this very uniform fragment sighs and
after application cDNA library
generation which leads us which gave us
confidence that potentially the
sequencing data that we have here is
bones
again I have these a free representative
samples so we have cd inequality and all
of the libraries were denuded bone into
10 and in most cases and the without
dilution we had very large feet so again
the bottom sample here in sample 11 was
the sample that was the needs degraded
of these three representative samples
and what you can see from this is that
we generated fairly clean live reads
with substantial yield and as you go
again with the increasing RNA
degradation you can see that the quality
quantity libraries there can be mounted
like we were able to generate is
diminished
okay so far the RNA sequencing so we had
these 16 my parents were submitted to
and this is CV which is the center near
for computational biology which run the
sequencing facility as a core facility
and so we submitted the samples in july
i believe and then the final budget
something they were running batches on
the system I would simply just go in a
queue system and the final camper boxes
were delivered to us in mid-august and
so the intimate details leaves a high
six 2400 system we selectively paired
and debate there reads and then we used
and basic computational and programs to
generate and like Tom had and couplings
to generate some basic stats and in
conjunction with what we got from the
core we also i also work and collaborate
with a viral form an assist and spadina
type of youtuber and what she did would
take the raw data and generate basic
metrics and align the read separately
because a big component of the work we
wanted to is actually establish new
algorithms for looking at ffpe tissue
significant think that the current
algorithms that are designed for highly
purified you know non degraded RNA are
and in essence ideal for FFPE samples
and what a big role that she has claimed
is looking at designing new algorithms
around F&P
okay so this is just a pretty
complicated a sample is so it's a what
some of the things we look for for QC I
guess is probably best way to look at
there so we submitted all of our samples
he identified to the even think facility
and on this chart we have been dating
they work on on the sequencer we have
the flow cell ID for them we have the
adapter ideas that we do so we were all
done and duplexes so we've used for
different adapters that are two
different hairs and these days people up
here to front of me and then in the
comment section I just have marked where
we had a series of original samples
which didn't have any rats and then we
actually included a couple of the
samples we had three technical reference
only attitude so we have sample 64 we
have three reps for the 93 runs with the
tumor and for example 64 we had to so
this is just access so part of what
wanted to hear is also accept sample to
sample variability and within a given
Lane sequencing and then sample to
suffer variability across multiple lanes
and then then batch to batch variability
when it's a hole for one on different
things at different times
as I mentioned previously ribosomal RNA
when we've tested a number of difference
by preferred methods and initially when
we had started I've assessing for the
over a year and a half ago we had not
all about potentially removing the
ribosomal RNA as you wanted to see what
the ribosomal RNA component was one of
the first things we gave me to actually
remove ribosomal RNA but the result of
that study was that up to i think it's
between forty and sixty percent of our
reads were generated where m ribosomal
and origin my ribosomal mi Tekonsha than
are in arjun so ugly going forward from
there we wanted to then assess the fame
sample types with the ribosome of
occasion in place so this is just a flat
he showed that the fiber zero step for
writers on with the patient that was run
on these samples resulting in less than
point one percent ribosomal RNA still
present in the sequencing data so even
though this looks like they vary
dramatically I mean everything comes are
quite vocal sense so it's ninety-nine
point nine percent free of ribosomal RNA
and some some of the key metrics we
wanted to look at as I said this is a
paired end and run and so what you can
see here is the r 1 represents the sigma
at the beginning direction with reeds
and then the arts who represents the
back end and actually one thing we do
know is significant we need more reads
on the r one end versus to the r 2 n so
we're still looking into this but
overall and we were able to uniquely
align twenty to sixty percent of the
reeds to the hue genome 19 and so when
you correlate this with the RNA input
degradation level it actually cover
mates well the twenty percent of one
sort of no unique alignment and
correlate with with degradation levels
and the ones that are higher with less
segregation ok just to hone in on some
of the sequence performance metrics oh
and I just pulled out a representative
sample so and who catered for example 6
and on the left-hand side so initially
when the gunner takes a look at this
data she lines everything and then she
goes in and looks at what and uniquely
aligned and so on the left-hand side you
can see the difference with the center
difference between once totally aligned
and what uniquely line so basically the
majority of what the lining is actually
week in most cases irrespective of
direction respecting the sample type and
we see this across the board and and
then on the right hand side we also look
at the alignment distribution so we look
at the ribosomal RNA and component which
is / to be non-existent and the eggs and
eggs on region the intronic region and
intergenic and so in most cases here you
will see that in trying to regen makes
of the majority of the unique reads
followed by the Exxon and then
togetic and again this is earning
existence across all the samples we have
fun samples previously by different
sequencing methods and seeing lightly
different profile we've seen lightly
more exams then intronic levels so at
the moment we're looking at how do we
compare different library prep records
to see and what the differences are in
terms of coverage and percentage
distribution and plain so i just looked
at one representative sample and this is
them for the whole entire cohort so this
is looking at 16 to normal parents of 32
samples so on average there was about 75
million reads and found the 50 be
prepared and reads were paint and with
ninety-five percent confidence interval
calculated and the me the me unique
aligned reads are shown the playbook
year so for the mapping to the HD 19 we
have about thirty nine percent
intergenic 8.5 intronic thirty percent
and examine fifteen percent of it said
the records on all components which
become a nuisance so you can see how
distinctive features are across the
whole cohort which was a nice spread
okay so i had mentioned that we had run
technical replicates tumor tumor and
benign cares and so in this particular
sample said on the left hand side we
have the three technical records for the
tumor the tumor and the tumor sample and
so what this is is it just took all the
transcripts gene information plotted
each of the technical rex against each
other calculated a person and
correlation coefficient and so you can
see in the case of sample of rap1 and
sample rep2 we have strong important
7.93 and between sample 1 and 3 we have
point I'm to and between example 1 and 2
we have put 92 as well so there was
relatively good concordance for the
technical replicates in this particular
sample case these three were all run on
different lanes and under and two were
run on the same batch one with another
different batch for the benign herring
we saw a very similar and profile and
again the correlation coefficient
arranging it is on 2 so all of these
scatter plots well as he loves the to
scale and there was excellent
correlation
and in order to sort of dig down a
little better into you and what the best
normalization strategy is to compare all
of these cells and all the transcripts
across and the different samples across
the different place different runs and
we looked at identifying a panel of
housekeeping genes that could be used
for global normalization or sample
sample nullification and so we don't do
the normal has given gene 9,000 gene so
actv gap eh lbh a EG m p chem 1a l do a
k1 into PRT chilean them yep cakey and
g6pd and these are well characterized
and a Dodge initely expressed are
endogenously expressed genes that should
be prevalent in a most and supple tights
and so what we looked at is we looked at
the within a given case so the tumor
normal pairs we looked at the
correlation of in not these nine genes
with indicates and so what you can see
here is I flooded six representative
samples and the correlation of these
nine genes across those samples and so
generally in most cases with the
exception of up to sample hairs that we
had this G normalization which gave a
linear rate given linear correlation
above an Oxford value of 19 and so
initially we have thought that using a
global organization strategy initially
for this case it would work but we based
off base in the face of the fact that
with sub optimal results forget you
decided to use a normalization sorry for
each of the individual examples in and
of themselves and then apply a global
normalizer afterwards
okay so um so in order to assess
initially what was going on with the
examples we have a panel of hallmarks of
prostate cancer so it speeds in and
around 100 110 and genes which are
associated with cust a cancer
progression diagnosis lethality and so
initially to assess the quality of the
data and initially to assess if there
was overarching themes around what's
going on between the tumor benign sample
populations we extracted the information
to FP km values for these particular
particular gene said we normalized all
of these genes so it's at nine marker
house husband between panel and then we
and we normalized we averaged all the
we've got the mean of all the tumor
samples in a case of 16 tumor samples
into 16 benign samples and then looked
at the differential expression between
the tumor benign groups as as a whole
and plotted and so what you see flooded
here is the log to differential between
tumor / benign or this panel of around a
hundred collected samples and what you
see here is a threshold market in which
represent the post- two-fold
differential as threshold and so what we
really wanted to do was just look at for
these [ __ ] cats are hallmarks and one
where there was significant differential
expression observed and would we be able
to see with this statistically
significant within our cohort and so and
the six genes that we initially focused
on is f cam win five a keratin 15
tgf-beta 3p 63 and value of a and so
when you go in and look at the tumor and
benign populations in and up and down
and generate some statistics and boxplot
zombies you can see
in the five out of the six cases that we
have here we had statistically
significant and differential expression
so in the case of the outcome samples
when you compare the benign population
within our cohort the tumor population
we have a p-value is greater than points
x 0 0 1 or the keratin 15 actually for
the character good theme and for the p63
statistical significance was you know
extremely high and between these two and
then also and that's significant with
still statistically significant is the
tdf fading 3 and Reggie FA and so where
we are with is right now is that we've
just completed all the QC on these
samples and the next phase is now to go
back to the transcript data that we've
generated and the isoform data and
actually with confidence use these
prostate cancer associated genes and as
validation to go back and look at maybe
novel and jeans that are differentially
expressed but are not included in our
hallmark of prostate cancer in our panel
and also to come back and and look at
some populations within our cohort so
this is just looking at separating humor
of the nine pairs I am into two groups
but what we would like to go back in and
do and the number thing you want to do
we want it within our cohort will have
african american and european american
and subpopulations we want to go and
separate those out and not the different
with pressure between the American
cohort and the European American cohort
we also want to go in and take a look at
a huge stratified and relative to the
Gleason score so how know with low-grade
prostate cancer diagnosis or high grade
classified as the White House is coming
tonight eight these populations above
the beginning afraid to express their
and then another aspect of all of this
as I said was that we wanted to look at
all the sequencing data and see if they
were methods in which we could interpret
first of all what flossed relative to
our fresh frozen
so what I had said we have fresh frozen
sample film also and our native
libraries were prepared on sequence we
have that data as sort of a benchmark
and we want to compare this effort the
data to that to see what's being lost
and through degradation or these
patients are these samples and then if
there's any algorithms that we could
sort of predict based off degradation
level what you should expect is the
chromosomal regions that would be
affected and firstly just the size of
the gene transcripts and relate to
degradation levels you know if the GC
content the issues that we're talking
about here and so on and so forth so
these are all subject to for the studies
that we are currently working on ok so
the follow up with here is you know we
have data analysis of the protos and as
I said and we have a plan to compare
these two fresh rose and Blanche cases
and we want to look at developing these
novel algorithms that will handle
athletes that was better and also more
importantly if we can look after if we
look at the QCT RNA from these ftp
coming make a decision to go or no-go
decision around whether they're feasible
for sequencing or not and based off what
that degradation profile looks like and
then obviously any sort of validation
signatures that are found you'd have to
do biological significance assessment
and follow up put some validation of any
game targets by rt-pcr okay so instead
of my collaborator and all of this is
vanity coochie fish he is our farm for
medicines and she also worked at
dana-farber and from the Beckman side
being a me was the senior application
scientist you helped us get going on all
of its actually Rossi is a technician
who run all the automated processes and
has Sarah Simmons and came in and helped
with the method development and
implementation on our biomech system our
prostate cancer specimens actually come
from the girl
enter and the cohort was defined by the
treatment of our comrades who are
investigated here at dana-farber masam
alota is the director of sector ok and
so with that and I'm just going to open
up the human aid section see what
questions are coming in
okay so i'm looking at a question here
which is from the from magnolia Bostic
content of our trades so have you ever
tried additional dnase treatment of the
ffp RNA prior to library / and do you
know the difference between your intro +
XR on his library prev and not cell
phone one of the other likely prep
methods you use yes so have you tried
dean exclaims a bit we have we have
tried additional DNA treatment of the
FFPE samples them we haven't you had
need had limited success with that and
with examples of it looked at and yes we
do know that the difference that we see
in the in Toronto next eleven if its
budget to library prep I think what we
want to disseminate and because we don't
have a direct you don't have samples
from both cohorts or Ronan and
difference and lightly prep methods we
don't have a direct comparison to make
if we wanted to also understand but it's
just something we're seeing in terms of
the balance of degradation of those
samples as well so the idea we have now
is to run a small cohort across multiple
different library prep methods to
prepare directly what's happening in
those but we do did you know that it's
the function of the library and one of
the my preferred method what we use so
we looked at the truth League method we
looked at neutran & evasion we've looked
at a couple of different things and
we're starting to look into other novel
methods as well I think you baby push
for what we're doing is we need to focus
on prep methods will allow us to go to
so 400 nanograms because a fake focus
and push of the research we're doing is
looking at tumor heterogeneity and
looking at tumor microenvironment and so
we want to move to increasingly smaller
number of cells and look at the
differences
silk cell populations may be within a
gland within a great great scoring you
know with forgiving patients there may
be a number of tumor glands and there
may be a number of different scores or
agents are the flights key to be bland
we want to go in be able to look at
different clothes I'd within an
individual patient and to do that we
have to be able to extract smaller
environments material and as a
consequence of that have to look at
downstream applications where we can
have an input level that's much smaller
and so so the next question I have here
is from larissa Needham from University
of Virginia and so what method did you
use to defeat the ribosomal RNA and so
we used write a zero where the earth the
method we used to be or na we looked at
different ways of doing this and put the
ribosomal by the zero method is by far
the easiest simplest method and we've
had very good results with it and how do
you quantify the residual amount of
ribosomal RNA the totally RNA prep after
keep your application using the RNA ship
bioanalyzer so firm so we don't quantify
the right as i'm not correct at the
possibility but we don't quantify the
residual amount of ribosomal RNA we be
qualified so we just needs the agilent
bioanalyzer system and we just look at
what the trace looks like i think that
that's the question another i'm sure it
got answered your question Marissa I
mean maybe you can write another one if
that wasn't clear
okay so um I think that's all the
questions and that we had so i just want
to take an opportunity to thank you all
for listening and I'm going to get to
everybody you can commit to this work